the crush on her since a film she was in  Lonesome Dove Louie darling so I have to  add a hundred that may have been me  with almost preteens for me so then I  get to work with her she looked that the  same as she did back then and she's one  of our great Diane Lane reacts to  Matthew McConaughey and knitting he once  had a crush on his serenity co-star et  spoke with the actress on the red carpet  at the premiere of their upcoming drama  oh my gosh I know I'm dying I don't know  what to say about that I mean I want to  live up to that I think I blocked it out  I don't think he lied I think he did say  that to me day one and I just had like  whiteout I couldn't cope I said I'm  gonna see a character thank you for the  compliment I'm dying and you're too big  I got a feeling today is today today's  the day  [Applause]  [Music]